What does it mean to have hope? In difficult times, when the news is filled with war, climate change, and other disasters, remaining hopeful about the future can feel impossible. It might even feel irresponsible, like you're burying your head in the sand and ignoring the very real problems of the world. But psychologists' research have found that hope is not an unrealistic luxury. In fact, it's a necessity. cultivating hope, researchers have found, can help buffer people against the stress and trauma
拥有希望意味着什么？在困难时期，当新闻充斥着战争、气候变化和其他灾难时，对未来保持希望似乎是不可能的。这甚至可能让人觉得是不负责任的，就像把头埋在沙子里，无视世界上真实存在的问题。但心理学家的研究发现，希望并非不切实际的奢侈品。事实上，它是一种必需品。研究人员发现，培养希望可以帮助人们缓冲逆境带来的压力和创伤，
of adversity and can prompt us all to work to do good in the world. So what is hope and how does it differ from optimism or resilience? How can hope help people who are facing adversity and pain? What are the greatest sources of hope in people's lives? Is hope always positive or can having unrealistic or naive hope ever cause problems? And what can all of us do to cultivate a sense of hope in trying and uncertain times? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
并能促使我们所有人为世界做贡献。那么，什么是希望？它与乐观或韧性有何不同？希望如何帮助那些面临逆境和痛苦的人？人们生活中最大的希望来源是什么？希望总是积极的吗？拥有不切实际或天真的希望会带来问题吗？在充满挑战和不确定的时期，我们所有人能做些什么来培养希望感呢？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Chan Hellman, a psychologist and the founding director of the Hope Research Center at the University of Oklahoma. Dr. Helman's research is focused on hope as a psychological strength, and he develops hope-based interventions to help children, adults, and families coping with trauma and adversity. He has published more than 80 research studies and is the author of the book Hope Rising, How the Science of Hope Can Change Your Life.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是陈·赫尔曼（Chan Hellman）博士，他是一位心理学家，也是俄克拉荷马大学希望研究中心的创始主任。赫尔曼博士的研究专注于将希望作为一种心理力量，他开发了基于希望的干预措施，以帮助儿童、成人和家庭应对创伤和逆境。他发表了80多项研究，并著有《希望升起：希望科学如何改变你的生活》（Hope Rising, How the Science of Hope Can Change Your Life）一书。
Next is Dr. Jacqueline Mattis, a clinical psychologist and the dean of the School of Arts and Sciences at Rutgers University. She began studying hope through her research. on the role of religion and spirituality in the lives of African American and Afro-Caribbean youth and adults. She has also studied factors that contribute to volunteerism, civic engagement, altruism, compassion, empathy, forgiveness, optimism, and positive parenting in those communities. Dr. Madison Hellman were featured speakers at APA's 2023 convention in a session on the Psychology of Hope, and I look forward to continuing that discussion today. So thank you both
接下来是杰奎琳·马蒂斯（Jacqueline Mattis）博士，她是一位临床心理学家，也是罗格斯大学文理学院的院长。她通过研究宗教和灵性在非裔美国人和非裔加勒比裔青少年及成年人生活中的作用，开始研究希望。她还研究了促成这些社区中志愿服务、公民参与、利他主义、同情心、共情、宽恕、乐观和积极教养的因素。马蒂斯博士和赫尔曼博士是美国心理学会2023年年会上关于“希望心理学”会议的特邀演讲嘉宾，我期待今天能继续这一讨论。所以，非常感谢你们两位
for joining me. Great to be here. Thank you. Let's start with a definition, as we often do on speaking of psychology. What is hope? How do you define it? So the way that we define hope is, real simply, hope is the belief that the future can be better than today and that we have the power to make it so. I think it's really important to clarify that hope is a cognitive process, that it's a way of thinking rather than a feeling or an emotion that we might have. Dr. Mattis, does that resonate with you? Absolutely, yeah. Both the notion of pathways and the sense of agency that one can change the way that things are.
加入我的节目。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。我们像往常在《心理学谈话》中一样，从定义开始。什么是希望？你们是如何定义它的？我们定义希望的方式非常简单：希望是一种信念，即未来可以比今天更好，并且我们有能力实现这一点。我认为澄清一点非常重要，即希望是一个认知过程，它是一种思维方式，而不是我们可能拥有的某种感觉或情绪。马蒂斯博士，这与你有共鸣吗？当然，是的。无论是路径的概念，还是一个人可以改变现状的能动性意识。
So how is hope different from optimism or confidence, Dr. Mattis? So we think about optimism as the expectation that things will work out in the future, right? that same sort of cognitive sensibility that projects you into the future. The difference between optimism and hope is that while optimism is that expectation that things will work out, hope comes with that expectation plus a plan, right? The idea that things may work out, but you have something that you have to do and that you can do to make that outcome possible. So those are the distinctions. It's hope is a verb. Why is hope important for people, mental health and well-being, Dr. Helman?
那么，马蒂斯博士，希望与乐观或自信有何不同？我们认为乐观是对未来事情会好转的期望，对吧？那种将你投射到未来的认知敏感性。乐观和希望的区别在于，虽然乐观是对事情会好转的期望，但希望不仅包含这种期望，还包含一个计划，对吧？即事情可能会好转，但你必须做些什么，并且你可以做些什么来使这种结果成为可能。这就是区别。希望是一个动词。赫尔曼博士，为什么希望对人们的心理健康和幸福感很重要？
Sure. So the idea of navigating through daily stress, for instance, the ability to set goals, especially short-term, specific goals, can lead us into successful steps and can really promote that well-being. So it really becomes a protective factor when we are facing adversity of stress. What happens to people who lose hope physically and mentally, Dr. Mattis? One of the things that we know is that people who genuinely lose hope and we have to distinguish between people losing hope and people being afraid to sort of own the fact that they are hopeful, but they're scared about that reality, that they're hopeful, but there's a lot of anxiety. But when people genuinely lose hope, they become paralyzed. And that's a point at which we see people beginning
当然。例如，应对日常压力的想法，设定目标的能力，特别是短期的、具体的目标，可以引导我们迈出成功的步伐，并真正促进幸福感。因此，当我们面临压力逆境时，它确实成为了一种保护因素。马蒂斯博士，那些在生理和心理上失去希望的人会发生什么？我们知道的一件事是，真正失去希望的人——我们必须区分那些失去希望的人和那些害怕承认自己充满希望，但又对这种现实感到恐惧的人，他们充满希望，但伴随着很多焦虑。但当人们真正失去希望时，他们会变得瘫痪。这就是我们看到人们开始
to be suicidal, right? That sense of there is no point in being here because there is nothing that I can do to change the outcome of the things that I'm facing right now. So the end of hope is often the end of people's capacity to imagine why it means, why it's meaningful and possible to be alive. And are the physiological changes that people undergo as they're maybe losing hope for whether they're good or bad reasons, Dr. Hellman? Sure, you know, as you begin to lose hope, first of all, the loss of hope is really a process where we begin to experience barriers to the pathways or strategies to the goals that were the future that we desire. And so we might begin to experience anger, frustration, and anxiety. If we're unable to overcome those,
产生自杀念头的时候，对吧？那种认为留在这里毫无意义的感觉，因为我无法改变我现在所面临的事情的结果。所以，希望的终结往往是人们想象为什么活着是有意义和可能的这种能力的终结。赫尔曼博士，当人们可能因为好坏原因而失去希望时，他们会经历生理上的变化吗？当然，你知道，当你开始失去希望时，首先，失去希望实际上是一个过程，我们开始感受到通往我们所渴望的未来目标的路径或策略受到了阻碍。因此，我们可能会开始经历愤怒、沮丧和焦虑。如果我们无法克服这些，
we can slide into a sense of urgency where the difficulty becomes more of an agitated, anxious, really rash decision-making process, that it can ultimately lead to despair and desperation. So certainly hope as a framework for action impacts us both physically and psychologically. Now, people often think of hopefulness as a kind of personality trait, an outlook that you're either born with or you're not. But you've both written about how it's possible to cultivate hope. So how does one do that? I think you see that happening even in childhood. You see parents helping children to think about the big questions that are foundational to hope.
我们可能会陷入一种紧迫感，困难变成了更具煽动性、焦虑、非常草率的决策过程，最终可能导致绝望和孤注一掷。因此，希望作为一种行动框架，确实在生理和心理上影响着我们。现在，人们通常认为充满希望是一种人格特质，一种你天生就有或没有的观点。但你们两位都写过关于如何培养希望的文章。那么，一个人该怎么做呢？我认为你甚至在童年时期就能看到这种情况。你看到父母帮助孩子思考那些构成希望基础的大问题。
What's happening? What do you want? So you have to sort of ask questions that help you with the big imaginings around. What are the good things that you want to have happen? If optimism and hope are both rooted in the sense of a positive outcome can be, possible. What does that positive outcome look like? And it can be as simple as I want my bottle or I want a cookie or I want this person to be my friend, whatever it might be, asking the big questions about what do you want to have happen? And then what can you do to make it happen? So all of those
发生了什么？你想要什么？所以你必须提出一些问题，帮助你进行围绕这些问题的大胆想象。你希望发生什么好事？如果乐观和希望都植根于积极结果可能实现的意识中。那么那个积极的结果是什么样的呢？它可以很简单，比如“我想要我的奶瓶”或“我想要一块饼干”或“我想要这个人成为我的朋友”，无论它是什么，提出关于你希望发生什么的大问题。然后，你能做些什么来让它发生？所以所有这些
questions are implicit in the work of being hopeful. And we see those being socialized into young people. And to the extent that we can continue to socialize ourselves to ask those questions explicitly or implicitly, we can always cultivate hope. And, you know, Dr. Hellman mentioned the reality that part of hope involves the recognition that they're always going to be barriers. Life will happen to us along the way. And so being able to name what the barriers are and then think about how do I get through this particular thing and how do I reimagine. what the possibilities are. So you might start with one hopeful outcome. Barriers come into play.
问题都隐含在充满希望的工作中。我们看到这些被社会化到年轻人身上。只要我们能继续社会化自己，去明确或隐含地提出这些问题，我们就总能培养希望。而且，你知道，赫尔曼博士提到了一个事实，即希望的一部分包括认识到总会有障碍。生活会随之发生。因此，能够说出障碍是什么，然后思考我如何克服这件特定的事情，以及我如何重新想象
You realize that the thing that you wanted may not be possible, at least in the way that you imagined it at the beginning, and then being able to sort of pivot to something that is as closely related to the original outcome or something else that's desired. But always it's rooted in this sense of,
可能性是什么。所以你可能从一个充满希望的结果开始。障碍出现了。你意识到你想要的东西可能是不可能的，至少不是你最初想象的那样，然后能够转向与最初结果密切相关或其他渴望的东西。但它总是植根于这种意识，即
what do I want, how do I get there, how do I recruit the resources that I need to make that outcome happen? And I'm hearing you say that the hope is something that you learn from the earliest days of your life as a person. So, Dr. Helmut, let me ask you, what if you come from a very adverse background and you haven't really learned a lot of hope as a baby? What happens as you grow up? Can you learn to hope coming from that kind of adversity? Sure.
我想要什么，我如何到达那里，我如何招募我需要的资源来实现那个结果？我听到你说希望是你作为一个人从生命最初几天就学到的东西。所以，赫尔曼博士，让我问你，如果你来自一个非常糟糕的背景，而你作为一个婴儿并没有真正学到很多希望，当你长大后会发生什么？你能从那种逆境中学会希望吗？当然。
And that's really the foundation of a lot of the work that we're doing, how does trauma and adversity? rob us of hope. And, you know, certainly from those earliest days where we begin to potentially nurture a secure attachment with caring adults, when that is not in place or not as predictable, we begin to have struggles with regards to relationships and, you know, finding others trustworthy. Part of what we're finding is that You know, when we look at the future from the context of fear and worry, or we spend more time ruminating on past events, that these are some of the things that can really diminish our capacity for hope. It doesn't necessarily rob us of hope, but it influences the nature of the goals that we maybe begin to set. So, for instance, when we're in distress, our goals may be from an avoidant framework.
这确实是我们正在做的很多工作的基础，创伤和逆境如何剥夺我们的希望。而且，当然，从我们开始可能与照顾者培养安全依恋的最早日子起，当这种情况不存在或不可预测时，我们开始在人际关系方面挣扎，你知道，发现他人值得信赖。我们发现的一部分是，你知道，当我们从恐惧和担忧的背景下看待未来，或者我们花更多时间反思过去的事件时，这些都是真正削弱我们希望能力的事情。它不一定会剥夺我们的希望，但它会影响我们可能开始设定的目标的性质。例如，当我们处于困境时，我们的目标可能来自一种回避框架。
That is, what are the outcomes that we do not want to occur? And that very much is going to influence those pathways components. Whereas when we see that hope has been nurtured, there's more likely to be an aspirational potential for those goals. So it's not so much that hope is either something you have or don't have. It's just how those environments really begin to influence the nature of the goals we set, the pathways that we have available to us. And then, you know, I do some work right now with adjudicated youth. And so we begin to think about what future do I see possible for me.
也就是说，我们不希望发生什么结果？这将在很大程度上影响那些路径组件。而当我们看到希望得到培养时，这些目标更有可能具有抱负潜力。所以，希望并不是你拥有或没有的东西。这只是那些环境如何真正开始影响我们设定的目标、我们可用的路径的性质。而且，你知道，我现在和一些被判刑的青少年一起工作。所以我们开始思考我为自己看到了什么样的未来。
And how does that influence the goals and the planning that I engage in today? So if I don't, for instance, in some of these youth that I'm working with, you know, they see themselves transitioning to the adult correction system. And so why would they engage in program services today? So really, the work is around how do we interrupt that? And then how do we begin to nurture the idea of what is possible? for me that raises a question of people, for example, who are, say, sentenced to life in prison. How do you have hope when you know that you're pretty much going to be here forever?
这如何影响我今天参与的目标和规划？所以，如果我没有，例如，在我正在合作的一些青少年中，你知道，他们看到自己过渡到成人矫正系统。那么他们今天为什么要参与项目服务呢？所以，工作确实是围绕我们如何打断这一点？然后我们如何开始培养关于什么是可能的想法？对我来说，这提出了一个问题，例如，那些被判终身监禁的人。当你明知自己几乎要永远待在这里时，你怎么能有希望？
I mean, where do you find the resilience and the hope within yourself, Dr. Mattis? You know, I think one of the things that I find particularly profound about human beings is the fact that we are not, we're not content. fully or limited fully by our circumstance. So you find some of the most hopeful people in the conditions and settings that are, that one might imagine as hopeless, right, or as a kind of environment that would produce hopelessness. Part of hope is recognizing the parameters that you're actually operating in. So if you are sentenced to life in prison and you, you know, you may know the system well
我的意思是，你在自己内心深处哪里找到韧性和希望，马蒂斯博士？你知道，我认为我发现关于人类特别深刻的一件事是，我们并不完全满足，也不完全受限于我们的环境。所以你在那些人们可能想象为绝望的条件和环境中，或者作为一种会产生绝望的环境中，发现了最充满希望的人。希望的一部分是认识到你实际操作的参数。所以如果你被判终身监禁，并且你，你知道，你可能很了解这个系统
enough to know that it's right. It's true. You will never see the outside. but your hope is not linked necessarily to the outside. You can have hope about things that are going on on the inside of, you know, whether it's prison or wherever it might be. So people, and I don't think it's a compensatory thing. I think people find ways of figuring out how to create the bigness of life,
足以知道它是对的。这是真的。你永远看不到外面。但你的希望不一定与外面联系在一起。你可以对监狱内部正在发生的事情抱有希望，无论它是监狱还是其他任何地方。所以人们，我不认为这是一种补偿性的事情。我认为人们找到了弄清楚如何创造生活广度的方法，
given the space that they are operating in. And life can be large regardless of where you are, right? And so whether you're on the inside of a prison or in any other context, I think people find ways of imagining what is the, how big can this life be? And there are lots of people who find ways of achieving that. And there are people who are free and don't, right? Yeah, exactly. One of the things that I really like about what Dr. Mattis is talking about and just made me, you know, really start to think in this moment is, you know, in these various contexts, What are the drivers of hope?
考虑到他们正在操作的空间。无论你在哪里，生活都可以是广阔的，对吧？所以无论你是在监狱内部还是在任何其他环境中，我认为人们找到了想象生活有多大的方法。有很多找到实现这一目标方法的人。也有自由的人却没有，对吧？是的，完全正确。我非常喜欢马蒂斯博士所谈论的一点，这让我，你知道，在这一刻真正开始思考，你知道，在这些不同的背景下，希望的驱动力是什么？
And where do we find meaning and purpose, which is highly associated with our capacity to hope? And so, you know, whether it's developing social relationships, meaningful social relationships, and the context of corrections, and probably more to Dr. Mattis's areas, you know, even that context of spirituality and how that can influence. influence and be a significant driver of our hope. Is it possible to have too much hope and can having unrealistic or naive hope lead to problems in people's lives? Dr. Mattis, you're smiling.
我们在哪里找到意义和目的，这与我们希望的能力高度相关？所以，你知道，无论是发展社会关系，有意义的社会关系，以及矫正的背景，可能更多地针对马蒂斯博士的领域，你知道，即使是灵性的背景以及它如何影响。影响并成为我们希望的重要驱动力。拥有太多的希望可能吗？拥有不切实际或天真的希望会导致人们生活中的问题吗？马蒂斯博士，你在微笑。
I'm smiling. I'm smiling. Take this one. I don't know that I can imagine a world in which there is too much hope. You know, and again, I think that part of the miraculous and beautiful and magnificent thing about human beings is the way in which we can cultivate and blossom hope. And because hope is not easily calibrated as this amount of hope is enough. And then once you cross that barrier, it's too much. People can imagine outcomes that others can't imagine. And so while others may respond
我在微笑。我在微笑。回答这个问题。我不知道我能否想象一个充满太多希望的世界。你知道，再一次，我认为关于人类的神奇、美丽和壮丽的事情的一部分是我们培养和绽放希望的方式。而且因为希望不容易被校准为“这种程度的希望就足够了”。一旦你越过那个障碍，就太多了。人们可以想象别人无法想象的结果。所以虽然其他人可能会回应
to an individual as if they are too hopeful about the possibilities that lie ahead of them, all of us make it miles because people could only imagine inches and we decided that inches are just not enough. Like there's got to be something. When you think about our popular culture, I used to love watching Disney movies with my nephews and my God kids. And one of the things that I loved is that a lot of these Disney movies are about. There's a boundary that your parents or community says you should never cross because it's too dangerous to go beyond that place. there's always a kid who's like, but I wonder what's beyond there. And I think so I think hope is very much like that. It's the, we have to have at least some people in every family, community,
一个个体，好像他们对摆在面前的可能性太充满希望了，我们所有人都可能因为别人只能想象英寸，而我们决定英寸是不够的。就像一定有别的东西。当你想到我们的流行文化时，我过去喜欢和我的侄子和教子一起看迪士尼电影。我喜欢的一件事是，很多这些迪士尼电影都是关于。有一个你的父母或社区说你永远不应该跨越的界限，因为超越那个地方太危险了。总有一个孩子会说，但我很好奇那里有什么。所以我认为希望非常像那样。它是，我们必须在每个家庭、社区、
friendship group who wonders at the, but how big could it get? And who who figures out a plan to sort of cross the bridge from what others see as possible to the things that people dream is impossible. and then bridge from there to the other impossible setup that are out there. So I don't think you can have too much help. Dr. Hellman, you agree? I see you nodding. I'm just really excited about that framework. We actually talk about children's movies as a fantastic way to help teach and nurture hope among our youth, our young children. You know, every one of those Disney movies, the main character had a great.
朋友圈中至少有一些人，他们好奇“但它能有多大？”并且谁想出了一个计划，从别人认为可能的桥梁跨越到人们梦想中不可能的事情。然后从那里架起桥梁到外面其他不可能的设置。所以我认为你不可能有太多的希望。赫尔曼博士，你同意吗？我看到你在点头。我只是对那个框架感到非常兴奋。我们实际上谈论儿童电影作为一种帮助教导和培养我们青少年、幼儿希望的绝佳方式。你知道，每一部迪士尼电影，主角都有一个伟大的。
the main character had a pathway and had that agency and then experienced a tremendous barrier. I mean, that's the highlight of the movie. And then what I really love about using movies like that as a way to help teach hope is that in every case, especially in those Disney movies, the way the main character overcomes those significant barriers is almost always the same. And that's their friends. Their friends come together. And it just demonstrates that hope is such a social gift, you know, something that we can share. And so on one hand, we can help teacher think or children think about, you know, how do your friends help you overcome barriers?
主角有一条路径，有那种能动性，然后经历了一个巨大的障碍。我的意思是，那是电影的亮点。然后我真正喜欢使用这样的电影作为教导希望的方式是，在每一种情况下，特别是在那些迪士尼电影中，主角克服这些重大障碍的方式几乎总是相同的。那就是他们的朋友。他们的朋友聚在一起。这只是证明了希望是一种社会礼物，你知道，我们可以分享的东西。所以一方面，我们可以帮助老师或孩子思考，你知道，你的朋友如何帮助你克服障碍？
And then really, what is your role? You know, how do you help your friends when they're facing those difficulties? So it's just a fantastic. And I totally agree that, you know, this idea of how. having too much hope is I kind of understand where it's coming from, but I know the evidence so far isn't really supporting that there's sort of these negative consequences to too much hope. And to me, it further illustrates this, what I think will be an emerging conversation is this idea of collective hope. and, you know, that as an individual, we can face some frustrations and some barriers,
然后真的，你的角色是什么？你知道，当你的朋友面临这些困难时，你如何帮助他们？所以这只是一个绝佳的。我完全同意，你知道，这种关于拥有太多希望的想法，我有点理解它来自哪里，但我知道目前的证据并没有真正支持拥有太多希望会有负面后果。对我来说，它进一步说明了这一点，我认为这将是一个新兴的对话，即集体希望的想法。而且，你知道，作为一个个体，我们可以面对一些挫折和障碍，
but when we come together collectively, there's certain power in having a shared vision of what could be. Now, both of you have talked in other interviews about your own histories and life experiences that led you to become interested in hope and the science of hope studying it. Dr. Mattis, could you tell us your story first and then we'll talk to Dr. Helman? I had a colleague who used to talk about the idea that you, you know that you've lived a certain kind of life when you couldn't have predicted you're here from you there. And one of the things that I'm always attentive to is the reality that there's nothing that would have predicted me being here in the space that I am right now. when I think about, I talk about my great-great-grandfather a lot, right, because he is the first named, enslaved person that I know of in our family. Others who were enslaved in our family who, I don't know what their names were.
但当我们集体聚在一起时，拥有一个关于可能性的共同愿景是有某种力量的。现在，你们两位在其他采访中谈到了你们自己的历史和生活经历，这些经历导致你们对希望以及研究希望的科学产生了兴趣。马蒂斯博士，你能先告诉我们你的故事，然后我们再和赫尔曼博士谈谈吗？我有一位同事过去常谈论这个想法，即你，你知道你过着某种生活，当你无法预测你从那里来到这里时。我总是关注的一件事是，没有什么能预测我现在所处的空间。当我想到，我经常谈论我的曾曾祖父，对吧，因为他是我家族中第一个我知道名字的被奴役的人。家族中其他被奴役的人，我不知道他们的名字。
But I think about what Samuel Easton, who's my great-great-grandfather, I think about what he endured on an everyday basis, right? And the idea that he had to develop in his head, that it was possible for him to buy his way out into freedom and that it was possible to figure out how to buy his children into freedom and to buy his wife, which he never was able to do. But as far as our family story goes, but when there are externalities that you, that are so immense, right, systems and structures that are intent on your, your destruction, essentially, and on diminishing you and your humanity. And if he could find a way of imagining a set of possibilities that he then worked his way through, that for me is the ultimate example of, I don't think anything is possible. I would never ever say that, right? But I think much more is possible about our lives than we could have imagined.
但我想到塞缪尔·伊斯顿（Samuel Easton），他是我的曾曾祖父，我想到他每天忍受着什么，对吧？以及他必须在脑海中发展的想法，即他有可能通过购买自己的方式获得自由，并且有可能弄清楚如何购买他的孩子获得自由，以及购买他的妻子，但他从未能够做到。但就我们的家族故事而言，但当有你无法控制的外部因素时，对吧，那些旨在摧毁你，本质上是旨在削弱你和你的人性的系统和结构。如果他能找到一种想象一系列可能性的方法，然后他通过这些可能性努力工作，对我来说，这就是“我不认为任何事情是不可能的”的终极例子。我永远不会那样说，对吧？但我认为关于我们的生活，比我们想象的要多得多。
And I think about the fact that Sam Easton couldn't have imagined his great, great-grandchildren. He couldn't have imagined us in another country that he didn't even know about necessarily. And he couldn't have imagined that we would be able to achieve the things that he actually set in motion, right? Through small actions and the ways that he raised his twin sons and the way that they then learned to raise their children and the things that they moved out of our path so that other things were made possible, all of those things are, for me, the result of people, deciding to hope. And I'm very conscious of the fact that I am the, I am the result of my mother's hope, right? Her decision every day to struggle to educate her four children, despite enormous
我想到塞缪尔·伊斯顿无法想象他的曾曾孙辈的事实。他无法想象我们在另一个他甚至不一定知道的国家。他无法想象我们能够实现他实际上启动的事情，对吧？通过小的行动，以及他抚养双胞胎儿子的方式，以及他们后来学习抚养孩子的方式，以及他们从我们的道路上移开的事情，以便其他事情成为可能，所有这些事情，对我来说，都是人们决定去希望的结果。我非常清楚这样一个事实，即我是我母亲希望的结果，对吧？她每天决定努力教育她的四个孩子，尽管有巨大的
barriers and enormous challenges. And, you know, she got to see us get to the places where she hoped us into and beyond. So I'm, I'll leave it at that. I'm very conscious of the fact that I'm, I'm, I'm, the product of someone's hope, which also means I have responsibility to hope for my nephews and my nieces in ways that I, you know, were done for me. And, you know, we talk a lot in psychology about generational trauma, but what you're talking about is generational hope. Yes, yes, absolutely, absolutely. And without that, generations die.
障碍和巨大的挑战。而且，你知道，她看到了我们到达了她希望我们到达的地方，甚至超越了。所以，我，我就说到这里。我非常清楚这样一个事实，即我是某人希望的产物，这也意味着我有责任以别人为我做的方式，为我的侄子和侄女去希望。而且，你知道，我们在心理学中谈论了很多代际创伤，但你谈论的是代际希望。是的，是的，绝对，绝对。没有那个，几代人就会消亡。
Hmm. So, Dr. Hellman, what about your path? Yeah, so this could take a couple of days. So roughly in the eighth grade, I transitioned into homelessness. It was a conscious decision for me. And I spent my high school years as a homeless youth. And moving into homelessness was a short-term goal centered around well-being and safety. and, you know, spending most days in school trying to keep that hidden because I was really afraid to become involved in the system, you know, at that time.
嗯。那么，赫尔曼博士，你的道路呢？是的，这可能需要几天时间。所以大约在八年级时，我过渡到了无家可归的状态。对我来说这是一个有意识的决定。我度过了我的高中岁月作为一名无家可归的青年。进入无家可归状态是一个围绕幸福和安全的短期目标。而且，你知道，大部分时间在学校里试图保持隐藏，因为我当时真的很害怕卷入系统。
And so, you know, managed that through high school and then stumbled around for a while until I became successful in college. My first semester grade point average is a 0.56. I failed every class except advanced swimming and life-saving. I like to swim. But, you know, it really informs the work that I think about because I am every day in awe that I'm here and that I get these experiences of even being, here today with you both is such a blessing. And so I think why is that? And what, you know,
所以，你知道，在高中期间管理了这一点，然后跌跌撞撞了一段时间，直到我在大学里取得成功。我的第一学期平均绩点是0.56。除了高级游泳和救生，我挂了每一门课。我喜欢游泳。但是，你知道，它确实为我思考的工作提供了信息，因为我每天都敬畏我在这里，我得到了这些经历，甚至今天能和你们两位在一起也是一种祝福。所以我认为为什么会这样？以及什么，你知道，
and that's why for me, hope is a social gift. And there were important people in my life at really critical times that helped guide me into a future of what could be. And, you know, it brings back that importance of what future do I believe is possible. And helping children, youth and families understand that they matter and that that future that they deserve and can be a part of is possible. And now, Dr. Helman, a lot of your work focuses on developing hope-based interventions to help people dealing with trauma and adversity, which obviously you yourself did. What are some of those interventions? What did you learn from your experience that you're able to pass on now? Sure. So we actually have started to use.
这就是为什么对我来说，希望是一种社会礼物。在我生命的关键时刻，有重要的人帮助引导我走向一个关于可能性的未来。而且，你知道，它带回了“我相信什么样的未来是可能的”的重要性。并帮助儿童、青少年和家庭理解他们很重要，并且他们应得的、可以参与的未来是可能的。现在，赫尔曼博士，你的很多工作专注于开发基于希望的干预措施，以帮助处理创伤和逆境的人，这显然你自己也经历过。那些干预措施是什么？你从你的经历中学到了什么，现在能够传授给别人？当然。所以我们实际上已经开始使用。
use hope really more as a framework for action. Dr. Mattis made the comment at the very beginning that I love, hope is a firm. It is about taking action. And so it's the idea of how do we begin the process of client-centered or person-centered goal setting. Oftentimes the system infuses the goals that clients need to navigate through. But this is a process where they are having a a voice within the context of goals. So I'm talking about parents who have had their children removed and their system involved. So at what point do they get to be involved in setting goals for themselves and their families and then how our program services pathways to helping them achieve those kinds of goals?
使用希望作为行动的框架。马蒂斯博士在最开始发表了评论，我非常喜欢，希望是一个动词。它是关于采取行动的。所以这是关于我们如何开始以客户为中心或以人为中心的目标设定的过程。通常，系统会注入客户需要导航的目标。但这是一个过程，他们在目标背景下拥有发言权。所以我谈论的是那些孩子被带走并卷入系统的父母。那么他们在什么时候可以参与为自己和家庭设定目标，然后我们的项目服务如何成为帮助他们实现这些目标的路径？
Ultimately, we've taken that to an organizational framework where we're working to create hope-centered organizations like human services or health departments, etc. Dr. Mattis, you came to your interest in hope through studying religion and spirituality in African-American communities. Do you think that religion or spirituality is a necessary ingredient for hope? Or do atheists or people who don't consider themselves spiritual find hope in other places? I think there are different tools that people use to find hope for people who are religious or religiously spiritual, and I'll distinguish between the terms religiosity and spirituality, for people who are religious or religiously spiritual, their faith
最终，我们将其带到了一个组织框架，我们正在努力创建以希望为中心的组织，如人类服务或卫生部门等。马蒂斯博士，你通过研究非裔美国人社区的宗教和灵性，对希望产生了兴趣。你认为宗教或灵性是希望的必要成分吗？还是无神论者或不认为自己有灵性的人在其他地方找到了希望？我认为人们使用不同的工具来寻找希望，对于那些有宗教信仰或宗教灵性的人，我会区分宗教性和灵性这两个术语，对于那些有宗教信仰或宗教灵性的人，他们的信仰
can often be the source of their hope, right? So let me take a step back and define this and then come back to that point. So religiosity, we can think about as a system of beliefs that are codified, and passed along over time that help us understand big existential questions through the idea of the existence of a god or system of gods. So if you are religious, there's a god involved and there's a community involved because religio sort of comes back, that Latin word comes back to the notion of community. And so for people who are religious, a god or system of gods can be the foundation of the idea that there is something, bigger than us that is guiding how life unfolds. And for some people and some religious communities, the idea of a predestination that there is a bigness to a set of possibilities surrounding your life that you may not be aware of, but there is a God that is guiding you towards that.
往往是他们希望的来源，对吧？所以让我退后一步定义这个，然后再回到那一点。所以宗教性，我们可以认为是一个被编纂的信仰体系，随着时间的推移传递下来，帮助我们通过上帝或神灵体系存在的想法来理解大的存在问题。所以如果你有宗教信仰，就有一个上帝参与，并且有一个社区参与，因为“宗教”（religio）这个词回到了社区的概念。所以对于有宗教信仰的人来说，上帝或神灵体系可以是某种比我们更大的东西正在引导生活如何展开的想法的基础。对于一些人和一些宗教社区，预定的想法，即围绕你生活的可能性有一种广度，你可能没有意识到，但有一个上帝正在引导你走向它。
So that the idea that you are loved by God or that you are, especially for Judea Christian communities, the idea that you're loved by God, that there are things that you are going to accomplish as a purpose to your life helps reinforce a sense of hope. However, spirituality, in contrast to this idea of belief in God and in the rituals and practices and the texts around that, spiritual people believe in the idea that there is a sacredness to life that makes life and living things inviolable. So if I can be religious, and not spiritual. So I can have texts around me and have practices
所以，你被上帝所爱，或者你，特别是对于犹太-基督教社区，你被上帝所爱的想法，你将要完成的事情作为你生活的目的，有助于加强希望感。然而，灵性，与这种对上帝的信仰以及围绕它的仪式、实践和文本的想法形成对比，有灵性的人相信生活有一种神圣性，使生活和生物不可侵犯。所以如果我可以有宗教信仰，而不是有灵性。所以我可以有文本围绕着我，有实践
that I engage in and believe in a God, but not treat others around me as if their lives are sacred. And so, you know, I like to think about religio-spiritual people as people who believe in something bigger than themselves and also believe that fundamentally
我参与其中并相信上帝，但不像对待周围的人那样对待他们，好像他们的生命是神圣的。所以，你知道，我喜欢把宗教-灵性的人看作是相信比自己更大的东西，同时也相信从根本上
life is sacred. But there are atheists who are spiritual who believe that life is sacred in whatever way they construct that. And for them, it's the sacredness of life, that is the foundation and the idea that life is still filled with purpose. It may not involve a God, but it's still filled with purpose. And we are connected to each other in that purposefulness. That may be the foundation for them of that same sensibility. So at the roots,
生命是神圣的人。但也有有灵性的无神论者，他们相信生命是神圣的，无论他们如何构建它。对他们来说，这是生命的神圣性，是基础，以及生活仍然充满目的的想法。它可能不涉及上帝，但它仍然充满目的。我们在那种目的性中相互联系。这可能是他们那种相同敏感性的基础。所以从根本上说，
they're very similar. It's just God's absent for one set of people. Does that influence the degree of hope that a person might feel? So if you don't believe in a God or you don't believe in an afterlife? Are you possibly less hopeful than people who do think that there's something more? I don't believe that that's true. I think there are people who can be profoundly hopeful who do not believe in a God. And I think there are people who believe in God who are not hopeful at all. Right. So I think it's how we make meaning of the world and how we embrace, Dr. Hellman used the language of battering before to the extent that we see our lives and our presence here on this planet at this time as mattering. And the people around us as mattering, that I think helps shape the foundations of our
它们非常相似。只是对于一群人来说上帝缺席了。这会影响一个人可能感受到的希望程度吗？所以如果你不相信上帝，或者你不相信来世？你是否可能比那些认为有更多东西的人更少希望？我不认为那是真的。我认为有深刻希望的人不相信上帝。我认为有相信上帝的人根本没有希望。对。所以我认为这是我们如何赋予世界意义以及我们如何拥抱，赫尔曼博士之前使用了“重要性”的语言，只要我们看到我们的生活和我们此时此刻在这个星球上的存在是重要的。以及我们周围的人是重要的，我认为这有助于塑造我们
hope. And it doesn't have to be rooted in, I don't think there's either one of those stances, either being religious or being atheist, that influences the degree of hope that one has. I think it really is about how you make meaning in the world. And the extent to which you have the capacity, the joy of being able to imagine. And for some people, the capacity to imagine has been so squashed by others around them, by structures around them, that their hope may be much smaller,
希望的基础。它不必植根于，我不认为这两种立场中的任何一种，无论是宗教还是无神论，都会影响一个人拥有的希望程度。我认为这确实是关于你如何在世界上赋予意义。以及你拥有多大程度的能力，能够想象的快乐。对于一些人来说，想象的能力被周围的人、周围的结构压得太厉害了，他们的希望可能要小得多，
but it's not because of anything else than the fact that hope is a function of who is around you either saying, you know, fueling the fire or throwing water on it. So if you happen to find a life where you can make meaning and there are others around you who can, you know, add fuel to that fire and egg you on. And you can deauthorize those who are causing harm to you, which is not always easy, right?
但这并不是因为除了希望是围绕你的人的功能之外的任何其他原因，他们要么在火上加油，要么在上面泼水。所以如果你碰巧找到了一种可以赋予意义的生活，并且周围有其他人可以，你知道，给那把火加油并怂恿你。并且你可以取消那些对你造成伤害的人的授权，这并不总是容易的，对吧？
And deauthorizing means someone tells you that you will never be that big and you say, eh, I'm not listening. That's you. That's about, that narrative is about you or just watch me, right? So that capacity in people and the capacity to simply wildly ignore is a real tool in being able to fuel one's own hope. Dr. Helman, do you see that as well? I mean, have you ever made comparisons between people who are religious and spiritual and the level of hope that they might feel compared to other folks? Yeah.
取消授权意味着有人告诉你你永远不会那么大，而你说，呃，我不听。那是你。那是关于你的，那个叙述是关于你的，或者只是看着我，对吧？所以人们的那种能力以及简单地疯狂忽略的能力是能够激发自己希望的真正工具。赫尔曼博士，你也看到了吗？我的意思是，你有没有在有宗教信仰和灵性的人与其他人可能感受到的希望水平之间进行过比较？是的。
So I agree with everything that Dr. Mattis said. you know, that there are hopeful people who are atheists and there are hopeful people who are deeply, deeply religious and vice versa as well. I have been involved in some research where we've looked at youth and their participation versus lack of participation or not participating. And what we find is that youth who are engaging in prayer, for instance, do report higher levels of hope. But we also find that youth who engage in mindfulness and meditation also report higher levels of hope.
所以我同意马蒂斯博士所说的一切。你知道，有充满希望的无神论者，也有充满希望的深信宗教的人，反之亦然。我参与了一些研究，我们观察了青少年及其参与与缺乏参与或不参与。我们发现，例如参与祈祷的青少年确实报告了更高水平的希望。但我们也发现，参与正念和冥想的青少年也报告了更高水平的希望。
And so I think it's really more about a connectedness that Dr. Mattis, that spirituality aspect that we find meaning and purpose and, you know, faith or religion provides sort of some framework around that. What are the big questions yet to be answered in the areas that you're studying? Dr. Mattis, let's start with you. There's so many. I think the question of, one of the questions for me is how hope is linked to other human virtues.
所以我认为这更多的是关于一种联系，马蒂斯博士，那种灵性方面，我们发现意义和目的，而且，你知道，信仰或宗教提供了一些围绕它的框架。在你们正在研究的领域中，还有哪些大问题有待回答？马蒂斯博士，让我们从你开始。有太多了。我认为这个问题，对我来说，其中一个问题是希望如何与其他人类美德联系在一起。
So I'm really interested in the link between hope and one's willingness to be altruistic. or hope and one's willingness to engage in what I think about as the inconvenient virtues, forgive, right? So forgiveness. So what is it about some people's ability in some moments to imagine that a different kind of relationship is possible between them and others? Or a different kind of world is possible, especially in the kinds of times that we're seeing right now. And what does that mean in terms of our ability to either forgive? or extend ourselves to others, to allow ourselves to be open to seeing things from the standpoint of another human being who we may disagree with profoundly and may not like, but need to figure
所以我真的对希望与一个人利他主义的意愿之间的联系感兴趣。或者希望与一个人参与我所认为的“不便的美德”的意愿，宽恕，对吧？所以宽恕。那么，是什么让一些人在某些时刻能够想象他们与他人之间可能存在一种不同类型的关系？或者一种不同类型的世界是可能的，特别是在我们现在看到的这种时代。这对于我们宽恕的能力意味着什么？或者向他人延伸自己，允许自己开放，从另一个我们可能强烈不同意且可能不喜欢的人的角度看待事物，但需要弄清楚
out how to embrace their humanity. So I think for me that the question of the link between hope and the inconvenient virtues is a real issue. And I would love to see studies of hope in children. So children experience life and life's barriers in very different ways than adults do. And I don't see a lot of studies on how six-year-olds who are faced with a moment where they can imagine and dream and plan a pathway, how they do that, and how they ignore the adults who tell them, oh, that's not possible. You can't do that, right?
如何拥抱他们的人性。所以我认为对我来说，希望与不便的美德之间的联系是一个真正的问题。我很乐意看到关于儿童希望的研究。所以儿童体验生活和生活障碍的方式与成年人非常不同。我没有看到很多关于六岁孩子在面临一个可以想象、梦想和规划路径的时刻时，他们是如何做到的，以及他们如何忽略那些告诉他们“哦，那是不可能的，你不能那样做”的成年人的研究，对吧？
And then they just become their purests. beautiful six-year-old selves and like they go off and do the thing. And then they look back at you like, ah, tell me another thing I can't do. So I think master hopers at early ages, I would love to see a set of studies on. And Dr. Helman, what were your big questions? What are you looking at now? So sure, first of all, I'd love to read those studies that Dr. Mattis just said that she would like to see her as engaging in. I will say that we actually just worked with a school district in the state of Washington where they had a parent teacher or a parent night and the elementary aged youth, first, second, third, fourth, fifth graders taught their
然后他们只是成为他们最纯粹的。美丽的六岁自我，就像他们走开并做了那件事。然后他们回头看着你，就像“啊，再告诉我一件我不能做的事”。所以我认为早期的希望大师，我很乐意看到一系列的研究。赫尔曼博士，你的大问题是什么？你现在在看什么？所以当然，首先，我很乐意阅读马蒂斯博士刚才说她想看到的那些研究。我会说我们实际上刚刚与华盛顿州的一个学区合作，他们有一个家长老师或家长之夜，小学年龄的青少年，一年级、二年级、三年级、四年级、五年级的学生教他们的
parents about hope. So it was a hope-centered curriculum in that space, which was fun to watch. So we'll see. We'll see what the data says on that. The two areas that come to mind for me that I'm really interested right now is the new sort of conceptualization of collective hope using goals, pathways, and willpower, that we exist in a social environment. And so I think about the importance of a community coming together with a shared vision of what could be. And that as an individual, I might be frustrated and overwhelmed, but that together we can find those pathways and strategies. is a shared energy. And so I'm really interested in that in the context of social movements.
关于希望的家长。因此，那是一个以希望为中心的课程，观察起来很有趣。所以我们拭目以待。看看数据会说明什么。目前我最感兴趣的两个领域是关于集体希望的新概念化，即利用目标、路径和意志力，我们存在于一个社会环境中。因此，我思考的是一个社区带着对未来的共同愿景聚集在一起的重要性。作为个人，我可能会感到沮丧和不知所措，但只要在一起，我们就能找到那些路径和策略。这是一种共享的能量。所以我对社会运动背景下的这一点非常感兴趣。
And also in the context of climate change, perhaps. And then the final area that I'm also interested in is how do we use the framework of hope to advance social policy? We have such a tremendous divide. And so it makes me wonder if we start with the idea of identifying common goals such as well-being, that it's the pathways we can debate, and that if we collectively can come together that well-being is the common goal, then the framework of hope may be a framework to help resolve tremendous conflict. Well, this has been really interesting. I appreciate
也许还有气候变化的背景。最后，我感兴趣的另一个领域是，我们如何利用希望的框架来推进社会政策？我们之间存在巨大的分歧。这让我不禁思考，如果我们从确定共同目标（如福祉）开始，那么我们可以争论的是路径；如果我们能集体达成共识，即福祉是共同目标，那么希望的框架或许能成为解决巨大冲突的框架。嗯，这真的很有趣。我很感激
both of you joining me today, and I thank you for the important work that you're doing and the hope that you're giving us all. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你们两位今天能加入我，我感谢你们所做的重要工作以及你们带给我们的希望。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的音频编辑是 Chris Kondyin。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。